madame monsieur bonjour la princesse de
galles lady di est morte cette nuit à
paris dans un accident de voiture elle
se trouvait avec son ami le milliardaire
saoudien dodi al fayed mort lui aussi
ainsi que le chauffeur de la voiture un
employé de l'hôtel ritz le garde du
corps de lady di lui est grièvement
blessé lady di et dodi al fayed était
arrivé hier à paris au sortir du ritz un
hôtel qui appartient au père de dodi al
fayed
leur voiture une mercedes noire a été
prise en chasse par des paparazzi
l'accident a eu lieu dans le tunnel du
pont de l'alma vers minuit le chauffeur
a perdu le contrôle de la mercedes qui
roulait semble-t-il à très vive allure
dodi al fayed et le chauffeur sont
semble-t-il mort sur le coup la
princesse elle est décédée quatre heures
plus tard à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière sur ces événements de la
nuit
le récit de pascal golomer
des tôles déchiqueté le moteur broyer
l'état de la voiture témoigne de la
violence extrême du choc il est zéro
enfant lorsque lady diana quittent le
restaurant de l'hôtel ritz en compagnie
de son ami dodi al fayed
un chauffeur de l'hôtel est au volant un
agent de sécurité de la princesse à ses
côtés mais la voiture est poursuivi par
plusieurs photographes à moto
elle pénètre dans le tunnel de l'alma en
plein paris à 100 150 km/heure peut être
plus le chauffeur perd le contrôle et la
voiture percute très violemment les
parois du tunnel lorsque la police et
les secours arrivent sur les lieux
dodi al fayed est déjà décédé tout comme
le chauffeur
la princesse de galles elle doit être
désincarcéré l'opération prend plus
d'une heure avant le transfert à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
l'enquète débute tout juste les
photographes sont interrogés les motos
saisies comme pièces à conviction
mais à 5h50 à l'hôpital le professeur
riou patron de l'équipe de réanimation
convoque la presse a mis en évidence une
plaie importante de la veine pulmonaire
gauche malgré la fermeture de cette
plaie et un massage cardiaque externe et
interne de deux heures aucune efficacité
circulatoire n'a pu être rétablie et le
décès défense tâter à 4 heures du matin
quant aux journalistes photographes ils
sont toujours entendus quai des orfèvres
par les enquêteurs de la brigade
criminelle